think
that you're the only one whose life is
hell because of this
live do this live do that
i'm sick of it no don't don't think of
it
i want to hear him scream don't you
touch me did somebody say you could talk
both of you shut up
hit him again
don't do it [__]
don't hit me more orders out of you pal
i don't believe you i don't believe you
if you knew
half
of what this prick
has done
somebody needs to take him out
i just
didn't know you felt the same way as i
did i've never had anything you don't
listen to her she'll turn on you the way
she's turned on shut up
when this son of a [__] is out of the
picture
i'm gonna need a new partner
what about craig
i got creek and wrapped around my little
finger
the same goes with munch and finn
dale if i say the word
you're in
think about it dale
i like this happening
we like it because
we get each other
we're connected
the connected
yeah
let's take care of the third wheel
all right
just wait one second
i want him to watch
watch what
watch this
[Music]
friends
how'd you know
stuck you said you went to get sushi
you and raw fish
[Music]
we need to check you out no i'm not hurt
you could have us finally oh no really
i'm fine you should go to the hospital
don't worry about maybe please help her
check
you've got to get inside there please
hurry you're gonna have to stay back
you've got to load it back captain you
can't go any closer it's my partner's
wife the passenger airbag didn't deploy
it needs to be deactivated before
anybody can go win that she's pregnant
and the baby could be in distress i'm
not going to get anybody killed here if
that bag blows up how's the other driver
just a scratch
caught reeks of booze line the tires to
stabilize the vehicle
bag's dead
why can't you use the jaws of life we
will but they got to stabilize our head
and neck before we could do anything
else heart rate's up
it's not enough room to get her bt and
she's still unconscious what about the
baby can't tell that cather's pretty
tight over there i got out i can get
back in
watch your head
capture let me help you watch yourself
you got to cut the roof let go let's do
it okay listen to me
place one hand on either side of her
head and hold her neck steady
good
she's waking up kathy okay
kathy trying to live yeah try not to
move okay
we were in an accident but everything's
okay and we're gonna get you out of here
okay
sorry
my water broke
i need you to fit this around her neck
the chin goes here i'm gonna put this
around your neck okay
[Music]
good work now keep your hands on or keep
you steady you're doing great okay
maria
do you remember your last birthday
yes
do you remember what you were wearing
a pink dress
with a big yellow bow and mama let me
wear her gold bracelets even though they
were too big
i blew out the candles on my first try
i've seen her
before i'm switching to the portable
olivia what's happening
i'm looking for something that might
help us find you hold on i'm looking for
what i don't understand sweetheart i
need you to hold on right now okay what
is it liv
montreal svu did a mailing to all
precincts
photos of a girl i know that i have them
yeah i'm tired can we stop talking now
no baby i need you to just to hang on
okay just one second why don't you sing
me a song let's check the firework
good
sing me a song sweetie what's your
favorite song i don't know yes you do
you know your favorite song just sing it
to me right now
god knows how long we have until they're
still fight guys
[Music]
montreal svu has seen her in dozens of
porn shots never able to identify
i got it
it's her
it's her she said there was a picture of
a garden on the wall are you convinced
this man is one of the worst child
pornographers they've ever seen and they
don't know a thing about him i wish i
could take it back
well then you'd still be his prisoner i
didn't kill him to escape
well why do you think you killed him
brittany it's okay you can tell me
he kept
[Music]
trying to convince me to go outside with
him go where
i begged him not to make me well he
conditioned you to never leave that room
that's why you were afraid no i wasn't
afraid i just didn't want to do it
do what
find someone else for him
[Music]
he said i was getting too old
he was using you as bait
he said i could stay
but only if i could find someone younger
brittany
you killed him to save another little
girl from going through what you did
he would have stolen her entire
childhood just like he stole yours
[Music]
i was only dead
it's okay honey
it's gonna be okay
[Music]
even if you tell people that i shot
myself
they're not gonna believe you now
they're gonna
assume that you shot me
in cold blood
[Music]
execution style
friends are here
let's make it interesting
testing testing
this is william lewis here
i'm here with sergeant benson
we're playing a little game of russian
roulette
we're halfway through
i'm sliding the gun across the table to
sergeant benson
there's three chambers left
one bullet
pick it up
[Music]
shhh
hold the trigger olivia
or i will
[Music]
do it now
they're coming
[Music]
where the hell are they the ground floor
is clear they're not outside two
chambers left
one bullet
you know how lucky i am
go away
go away amelia
[Music]
came over
say goodbye olivia
[Music]
this is the last thing
you're gonna think about
before you die
[Music]
the last thing
you're gonna see
[Music]
finn
if i'm not under arrest i want to go
you said you had a business meeting
that's right so why have you got mud on
your shoes
[Music]
get off me i can't do this
as soon as a lab gets this they're gonna
tell us exactly where you buried her
last chance richard
where is she
live look at this burnt wood felipe's
burgers burnt down there was charred
beans
she's in the empty lot
divide it up look for any disturbed or
darker earth footprints let's go
[Music]
i got something
this ground's been disturbed
footprint
we need to dig get some tools okay you
could get pieces of fence anything
[Applause]
[Music]
wait
the hell is this
[Music]
i smell plural oh god
help me lift her up
come on
she's not breathing
okay
stay with me come on maria
come on girl come on yeah
it's okay
good girl it's okay
hold up
you